‏i want do
something انء
الله
[Silence]
‏k
‏me extra micr from the office me extra
micr from
[Silence]
office
‏if we can have the kid st or they
have all the
kids all
right ky you ready ‏all right come on
up
come all right so brother kyle kyle is
in lo
here he works for big fortune 500
company that's all we say we won't
disclose the rest of right or we might
come and ask you for donations you know
not ‏all right you
ready hold up
to after
me اهد اه
ان اله ال الله الله واشهد
واهد
مح
عدهه i
be there is
‏wor and be and be
م serv تكبير
اكبير اكبر
تكبير
ان شاء
الله ان شاء
[Silence]
الله
‏all
sch
scha
so
انء
الله ان شاء
الله ان اللهن
[Silence]
تعالى
الله
ق30 40 ان شاء
[Silence]
الله
تراوح صلاه قيام
اللي خلاص ان شاء
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قام السواء الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيموا اعتدلوا استووا سووا الصف
سدوا الخ
[Silence]
خلل الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
عم
يتساءلون عن النبا
العظيم الذي هم فيه
مختلفون كلا سيعلمون ثم كلا
سيعلمون الم نجعل الارض
مهادا والجبال
اوتادا
وخلقناكم ازواجا وجعلنا نومكم
سباتا وجعلنا الليل
لباسا وجعلنا النهار
معاشا وبنينا فوقكم سبعا
شدادا وجعلنا سراجا
وهاجا
وانزلنا من المعصرات
ماء
ثجاجا لنخرج به حبا
ونباتا
وجنات
الفافا ان يوم الفصل كان
ميقاتا يوم ينفخ في الصور فتاتون
افواجا وفتحت السماء
فكانت
ابوابا وسيرت الجبال فكانت
سرابا ان
جهنم كانت
مرصادا للطاغين
مابا لابثين فيها
احقابا لا يذوقون فيها
بردا ولا
شرابا الا حمي
وغساقا
جزاء
وفاقا انهم كانوا لا يرجون
حسابا وكذبوا
باياتنا
كذابا وكل شيء احصيناه
كتابا فذوقوا فلن نزيدكم الا
عذابا ان للمتقين
مابا حد
ان للمتقين
مابا ان
للمتقين مفازا
حدائق
واعنابا وكواعب
اترابا
وكاسا
دهاقا لا يسمعون فيها لغو
ولا
كذابا
جزاء من ربك
عطاء
حسابا رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما
الرحمن الرحمن لا يملكون منه
خطابا يوم يقوم الروح
والملائكه صف بل لا
يتكلمون لا
يتكلمون الا من اذن له الرحمن وقال
صوابا ذلك اليوم الحق فمن
شاء اتخذ الى ربه
مابا
انا
انذرناكم
عذابا قريبا
يوم
ينظر المرء ما قدمت
يداه ويقول الكافر يا ليتني
كنت
ترابا الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين
والنازعات غرقا
والناشطات نشطا
والسابحات
سبحا
فالسابقات سبقا فالمدبرات
امرا يوم ترجف
الراجفه تتبعها
الرادفه قلوب
يومئذ
واجفه ابصارها
خاشعه
يقولون انا
لمردودون في الحافره ائذا كنا عظاما نخ
قالوا تلك اذا كره
خاسره
فانما هي
زجره واحده فاذا هم
بالساهره هل اتاك حديث موسى اذ ناداه ربه
بالوادي المقدس طوى اذهب الى فرعون انه
طغى
فقل هل لك الى ان تزكى واهديك الى ربك
فتخشى
فاراه الايه الكبرى فكذب وعصى
ثم ادبر يسعى فحشر
فنادى فحشر فنادى فقال انا ربكم
الاعلى اخذه الله نكال الاخره
والاولى ان في ذلك لعبره لمن
يخشى
اانتم اشد خلقا ام
السماء
بناها رفع سمكها
فسواها واغطش ليلها واخرج
ضحاها الارض بعد ذلك
دحاها اخرج منها
ماءها ومرعاها
والجبال
ارساها متاعا لكم ولانعامكم
فاذا
جاءت
الطا
الكبرى يوم
يتذكر انسان ما سعى وبرزت الجحيم لمن
يرى فاما من طغى واثر الحياه الدنيا فان
الجحيم هي
الماوى واما من خاف مقام ربه ونهى النفس
عن
الهوى
فان الجنه هي
الماوى يسالونك عن الساعه ايان
مرساها فيما انت من
ذكراها الى ربك
منتهاها
انما انت
منذر من
يخشاها
كانهم يوم يرونها لم يلبثوا الا
عشيه الا عشيه او
ضحاها الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ك
‏some
not
[Silence]
‏cl6
‏make
make
this
make he
pr again i just want
make
things and make doesn't
c st
do
‏over some
are you not he ask any
make make help you f out the things
properly and that more toy doesn't c you
anything you get re back from what you
to the st ofon and the r academy
‏so
wasn
earch
‏parad
church have
please please move that
car you know they enforcing towing and
booting the cars you guys won be happ so
we just ask you polly if you have a
carve
wor
‏there
going
i me
i7
think
‏respectfully ask you guys take
[Silence]
care استقيم اعتدلوا
استووا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين عبس و تولى ان
جاءه الاعمى وما يدريك لعله يزكى او يذكر
فتنفعه الذكرى اما من استغنى
فانت له تصدى وما عليك الا
يزكى واما من
جاءك يسعى وهو يخشى
فانت عنه تلهه كلا
انها تذكره فمن
شاء ذكره في صحف مكرمه
مرفوعه مطهره بايدي سفره
كرام برره قتل
الانسان ما
اكفره من اي شيء خلقه من نطفه خلقه
فقدره ثم السبيل يسره ثم اماته
فاقبره ثم اذا
شاء
انشره كلا لما يقض من
امره
فلينظر الانسان الى طعامه
انصب نا
الماء صبا ثم شققنا الارض شقا
فانبتنا فيها حبا
وعنبا
وقضبا
وزيتونا
ونخلا
وحدائق غلبا
وفاكهه
وابا متاعا لكم للانعام م فاذا
جاءت
الصاخه يوم يوم يفر المرء من اخيه
وامه
وابيه
وصاحبته
وبنيه لكل امرئ منهم
يومئذ شان
يغنيه
وجوه
يومئذ
مسفره
ضاحكه
مستبشره
ووجوه يومئذ عليها غبره ترهقها قتره
اولئك هم الكثره
الفجره بسم الله
الرحم اذا الشمس كورت واذا النجوم انكدرت
واذا الجبال سيرت واذا العشار عطلت واذا
الوحوش حشرت واذا البحار سجرت واذا النفوس
زوجت واذا الموعوده سئلت باي
ذنب قتلت واذا الصحف نشرت واذا
السماء كشطت واذا الجحيم سعرت واذا
الجنه
ازلفت علمت نفس من قد علمت نفس ما احضرت
فلا اقسم
بالخنس الجواري
الكنس والليل اذا عسعس والصبح اذا
تنفس
انه لقول رسول
كريم ذي قوه عند ذي العرش مكين مطاع ثم
امين وما
صاحبكم
بمجنون ولقد راه بالافق
المبين وما هو على الغيب
بضنين
فاين
تذهبون ان هو الا ذكر
للعالمين وما هو بقول شيطان
الرجيم فاين
تذهبون ان هو الا ذكر
للعالمين لمن
شاء منكم ان ي
قيم وما
تشاءون الا ان يشا
الله رب
العالمين
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليه
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا
السماء
انفطرت واذا الكواكب
انتثرت واذا البحار فجرت واذا القبور
بعثرت علمت
نفس ما
علمت نفس ما قدمت
واخرت يا ايها الانسان ما غرك بربك
الكريم الذي خلقك فسواك فعدلك في اي
صوره ما
شاء ركبك كلا بل تكذبون
بالدين وان عليكم
لحافظين كراما
كاتبين يعلمون ما
تفعلون
ان الابرار لفي نعيم وان الفجار لفي
جحيم يصلونها يوم الدين وما هم عنها
بغائبين وما ادراك ما يوم
الدين
ثم ما ادراك ما يوم
الدين يوم لا تملك نفس لنفس
شيئا والامر يومئذ
لله الله
ا
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيموا واستووا ترص واعتدلوا رسج
رك ان شاء الله
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويل للمطففين
الذين اذا اكتالوا على الناس
يستوفون واذا كالوهم او وزنوهم
يخسرون الا يظن
اولئك
انهم
مبعوثون ليوم
عظيم يوم يقوم الناس لرب
العالمين كلا ان كتاب الفجار لفي
سجين وما ادراك ما
سجين كتاب
مرقوم ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
الذين يكذبون بيوم
الدين وما يكذب به الا كل معتد
اثيم اذا تتلى عليه ايات
قال اساطير
الاولين كلا بل ران على
قلوبهم ما كانوا
يكسبون كلا انهم عن ربهم يومئذ
لمحجوبون ثم انهم لصالوا
الجحيم ثم يقال هذا الذي كنتم به تكذبون
كلا ان كتاب الابرار لفي
عليين وما ادك ما
عليون كتاب
مرقوم يشهده
المقربون ان الابرار لفي نعيم على
الارائك
ينظرون تعرف في وجوههم نظره نعي
يسقون من
رحيق
مختوم ختامه مسك وفي ذلك فليتنافس
المتنافسون ومزاجه من
تسنيم عينا يشرب بها
المقربون ان الذين اجرموا كانوا من الذين
امنوا
يضحكون واذا مروا بهم
يتغامزون واذا انقلبوا الى اهلهم ان قلبوا
فكهين واذا راو قالوا ان
هؤلا ل
ضالون وما ارسلوا عليهم
حافظين فاليوم الذين امنوا من الكفار
يضحكون على
الارائك
ينظرون هل ثوب الكفار ما كانوا
يفعلون بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اذا
السماء
انشقت واذنت لربها وحقت واذا الارض مدت
والقت ما فيها خلت واذنت لربها
وحقت يا ايها الانسان انك كادح الى ربك
كدحا فملاقيه
فاما من اوتي كتابه بيمينه فسوف يحاسب
حسابا
يسيرا
وينقلب الى اهله
مسرورا واما من اوتي كتابه
وراء ظهره فسوف يدعوا
ثبورا ويصلى
سعيرا انه كان في اهله
مسرورا انه ظن ان لن
يحور بلى ان ربه كان به
بصيرا فلا اقسم بالشفق
والليل وما وسق والقمر اذا اتسق
لتركبن طبقا عن طبق فما لهم لا
يؤمنون واذا قرئ عليهم القران لا
يسجدون الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بل الذين كفروا
يكذبون والله اعلم بما
يوعون
فبشرهم بعذاب
اليم الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات هم
اجر غير
ممنون بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والسماء ذات البروج واليوم
الموعود وشاهد
ومشهود قتل اصحاب
الاخدود النار ذات
الوقود اذ هم عليها
قعود وهم على ما يفعلون
بالمؤمنين
شهود وما نقموا منهم الا ان يؤمنوا بالله
العزيز
الحميد الذي له ملك السماوات والارض والله
على كل شيء
شهيد ان الذين فتنوا المؤمنين والمؤمنات
ثم لم يتوبوا فلهم عذاب جهنم ولهم عذاب
الحري ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار ذلك الفوز
الكبير ان بطش ربك
لشديد انه هو يبدئ
ويعيد وهو الغفور الودود ذو العرش المجيد
فعال لما يريد هل اتاك حديث الجنود فرعون
وثمود بل الذين كفروا في
تكذيب والله من
ورائهم
محيط بل هو قران مجيد في لوح محفوظ
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والسماء
والطارق وما ادراك ما الطارق النجم الثاقب
ان كل نفس لما عليها
حافظ
فلينظر
الانسان مما خلق خلق م
ماء دافق يخرج من بين الصلب والتر
ئب انه على رجعه لقادر يوم تبلى
السرائر فما له من قوه ولا ناصر
والسماء ذات الرجع والارض ذات الصدع انه
لقول فصل وما هو بالهزل انهم يكي دون كيدا
واكيد كيدا فمهل الكافرين امهلهم
رويدا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى ثم يموت
فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يم هل اتاك
حديث
الغاشيه وجوه يومئذ خاشعه
عامله ناصبه تصلى نارا حاميه تسقى من عين
انيه ليس لهم طعام الا من
ضريع لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع وجوه يوم اذ
ناعمه لسعيها راضيه في جنه عاليه لا تسمع
فيها لاغيه فيها عين جاريه فيها سرر
مرفوعه
واكواب موضوعه ونمارق
مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه افلا
ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت والى
السماء كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نصبت
والى الارض كيف سطحت فذكر انما انت
مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من تولى وكفر فيعذبه الله عذاب الاكبر
ان الينا
ايابهم ثم ان علينا
حسابهم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم كم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
بس
الله السلام علي ورحمه الله
وبركاته so i would like
requ both brother and sisters are
w be flight exit are this back there
شاء
الله ان شاء
الله
يلا
ما شاء
[Silence]
الله الحمد لله
تكبير عبد
اللهد
اللهد الله ما شاء الله
ع
اللهج ماء الله الله
ع الله اكبر الله
اكبر عبد الرحم عسل عبد
الرحمن
[Silence]
‏behind
تكبب ان شاء الله الله
سانه روزي
عسل الله
اكبر بسم
الله اعوذ بالله من الشيط الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم لا اقسم بهذا البلد وانت حل
بهذا البلد ووالد وما ولد لقد خلقنا
الانسان في كبد ايحسب ان لن يقدر عليه احد
يقول اهلكت مالا لبدا ايحسب ان لم يره
احد الم نجعل له عينين ولسان
وشفتين
وهديناهم نجدين فلق طحم العقبه وما ادراك
ما العقب فق رقب او اطعام في يوم ديي
مسغبه يتيما ذا مقربا او مسكينا ذا مطربا
ثم كان من الذين امنوا وتواصوا بالصبر
وتوا
بال المرحمه اولئك اصحاب الميمنه والذين
كفروا باياتنا هم اصحاب المشامه عليه نار
مص ما شاء الله
تكبير
الله
[Silence]
معراج
لا اقسم بهذا البلد وان تحل بهذا البلد
ووالد وما ولد لقد خلقنا الانسان في كب
ايحسب ان يقدر عليه جزاك الله تكبير في
المعراج ما شاء
الله اب
[Silence]
ع يلا
تكبير
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم والنازعات غرقا والناشطات
نشطا والسابحات سبحا فالسابقات سبقا
فالمدبرات امرا يوم ترجف الراجفه تتبعها
الرادفه قلوب يومئذ واجفه ابصارها خاشعه
يقولون اانا لمردودون في في الحافره اذا
كنا عظاما نخره قالوا تلك اذا كره خاسره
جزاك الله
تكبير جزاك الله
قصي
زهره معراج ما شاء
الله
[Silence]
تكبير عمر
شحتوت
عمر
[Silence]
‏unes
15د شاءك الله
خير مريم
عسل
مريم
[Silence]
‏place
خص اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم والنجم اذا هوى ما ظل
صاحبكم وما غوى وما ينطق عن الهوى ان هو
الا وحي يوهى علمه شديد القوى ذو مره
فاستوى وهو بالافق الاعلى ثم
فتدلى فكان قاب قوسين ادنى فاوحى الى عبده
ما
اوزاك الله
[Silence]
تكبير
‏c
[Silence]
15س
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والذاريات
ى ف الحاملات
وقرا فالجاريات
يسرا فالمقسمات ام
انما توعدون لصادق وان الدين لواقع
والسماء ذات الحبك انكم لفي قول مختلف
يؤفك عنه من افك قتل
الخراصون الذين هم في غمره
ساهون يسالون ايان يوم الدين يوم هم على
النار
يفتنون ذوقوا
فتنتكم هذا الذي كنتم به
تستعجلون ان المتقين في
جنات
وعيون اخذين ما اتاهم
ربهم انهم كانوا قبل ذلك
محسنين كانوا قليلا من الليل ما
يهجعون وبالاسحار هم
يستغفرون وفي اموالهم حق
للسائر
والمحروم وفي الارض ايات للموقنين
وفي
انفسكم افلا
تبصرون وفي السماء رزقكم وما توعدون ف
السماء والارض انه لحق مثلما انكم
تنطقون صدق الله العظيم ما شاء
الله
شاءك
16 رحمه عبد
[Silence]
الرق no no you didn't win you win sister
w all
تكبير all
عبد الرحمن
ع
[Silence]
رحمن ما شاء
الله
ان شاء الله بسم الله الرحمن
الرحي بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والذاريات
ذر فالحاملات
وقرا فالجاريات
يسرا فالمقسمات
امرا
انما توعدون
لصادق وان الدين واقع
والسماء ذات الحبك
انكم لفي قول
مختلف يؤفك عنه من افك قتل
الخراصون الذين هم في
غمره
ساهون يسالون ايان يوم
الدين يومهم على
[Silence]
تكب
‏has name
onel
all
ان
finish preview of kids are
and funding saw
earon comm where they
[Silence]
الله
استقيم انك
عف الله
اكبر بسم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين والفجر وليال عشر والشفع والوتر
والليل اذا يسره ال في ذلك قسم لذي
حجر الم تر كيف فعل ربك
بعاد ارم ذات
العماد التي لم يخلق مثلها في
البلاد وثمود الذين جابوا الصخر
بالواد وفرعون ذي
الاوتاد الذين طغوا في البلاد فاكثروا
فيها
الفساد فصب عليهم ربك سوط
عذاب ان ربك لبالمرصاد
فاما ال الانسان اذا ما ابتلاه ربه فاكرمه
ونعمه فيقول ربي اكرما واما اذا ما ابتلاه
فقدر عليه رزقه فيقول ربي
اهانا كلا بل لا تكرمون
اليتيم ولا
تحاضون على طعام المسكين
وتاكلون التراث اكلا
لما
وتحبون المال حبا
جما كلا اذا دكت الارض دكا دكا
وجاء ربك والملك صفا صفا
وجيء يومئذ بجهنم
يومئذ يتذكر الانسان
وانا له
الذكرى يقول يا ليتني قدمت
لحياتي فيومئذ لا يعذب عذابه احد ولا يوثق
وثاقه احد يا ايتها النفس
المطمئن ارجعي الى ربك
راضيه مرضيه
فادخلي في عبادي وادخلي
جنتي بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم لا اقسم بهذا البلد وانت حل بهذا
البلد ووالد وما ولد لقد خلقنا الانسان في
كبد ايحسب ان لن يقدر عليه احد يقول اهلكت
مالا لبدا ايحسب ان لم يره احد الم نجعل
له
عينين
ولسانا
وشفتين
وهديناه جدين فلا اقتحم العقبه وما ادراك
ما العقبه فك رقبه او
اطعام في يوم ذي
مسغبه يتيما ذا مقربه او مسكينا ذا متربه
ثم كان من الذين امنوا وتواصوا بالصبر
وتواصوا
بالمرحمه
اولئك اصحاب الميمنه والذين كفروا
باياتنا هم اصحاب المشامه عليهم
نار صده بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والشمس
وضحاها والقمر اذا تلاها والنهار اذا
جلاها والليل اذا
يغشاها
والسماء وما بناها والارض وما طحاها ونفس
وما
سواها فالهمها فجورها وتقوى
قد افلح من زكاها وقد خاب من
دساها كذبت ثمود بطغواها
اذ بعث
اشقاها فقال لهم رسول الله ناقه الله
وسقياها فكذبوه فعقروها
فدمدم عليهم ربهم
بذنبهم فسواه ولا يخاف
عقباها الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اه الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والليل اذا يغشى والنهار اذا تجلى
وما خلق الذكر
والانثى ان سعيكم لشتى فاما من اعطى واتقى
وصدق بالحسنى فسنيسره
لليسرى
واما من بخل واستغنى وكذب بالحسنى فسنيسره
للعسرى وما يغني عنه ماله اذا تردى ان
علينا للهدى وان لنا للاخره والاولى
فانذرتكم نارا تلظى لا يصلاها الا
الاشقى الذي كذب
وتولى
وسيجنبها
الاتقى الذي يؤتي مه
يتزكى وما لاحد عنده من نعمه تجزى الا
ابتغاء وجه ربه الاعلى لسوف
يرضى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والضحى
والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك وما قل ولا
الاخره خير لك من الاولى ولسوف يعطيك ربك
فترضى الم يجدك يتيما فاوى ووجدك
ضالا فهدى
ووجدك
ئلا فاغنى فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما
السائل فلا تنهر واما بنعمه ربك فحدث بسم
الله الرحمن
الرحيم الم نشرح لك صدرك ووضعنا عنك وزرك
الذي انقط ظهرك ورفعنا لك ذكرك
فان مع العسر يسرا ان مع العسر يسرا فاذا
فرغت
فانصب والى ربك فارغب بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والتين
والزيتون وطور
سينين وهذا البلد الامين لقد خلقنا
الانسان في احسن
تقويم ثم رددناه اسفل
سافلين الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فلهم اجر غير
ممنون فما يكذبك بعد
بالدين اليس الله باحكم
الحاكمين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله استقيم واستووا ذبي سجده تلا رك ان
شاء الله
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
الضالين
امين اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق خلق الانسان
من علق اقرا وربك الاكرم الذي علم بالقلم
علم
الانسان ما لم يعلم كلا ان الانسان ليطغى
ان راه استغنى ان الى ربك
الرجع ارايت الذي ينهى عبدا اذا صلى ارايت
ان كان على الهدى او امر
بالتقوى ارايت ان كذب
وتولى الم يعلم بان الله يرى كلا لئن لم
نته
لنسفعا
بالناصيه
ناصيه كاذبه خاطئه فليدع ناديه سندع
الزبانيه كلا لا تطعه واسجد
واقترب الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا
انزلناه في ليله القدر وما ادراك ما ليله
القدر ليله القدر خير من الف شهر تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن ربهم من كل امر
سلام هي حتى مطلع الفجر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم لم يكن الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب
والمشركين
منفكين حتى تاتيهم
البينه رسول من الله يتلو صحفا مطهره فيها
كتب قيمه وما تفرق الذين اوتوا الكتاب الا
من بعد ما
جاءتهم
البينه وما امروا الا ليعبدوا الله مخلصين
له الدين
حنفاء ويقيم
الصلاه ويقيم الصلاه ويؤتوا الزكاه وذلك
دين
القيمه ان الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب
والمشركين في نار جهنم خالدين فيها
اولئك هم شر البريه ان الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات
اولئك هم خير
البريه
جزاؤهم عند ربهم جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها ابدا
رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه ذلك لمن خشي
ربه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان مالها
يومئذ تحدث
اخبارها بان ربك اوحى لها يومئذ يصدر
الناس اشتاتا ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا يره ومن
يعمل مثقال
ذره شر يره بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والعاديات ضبحا فالموريات
قدحا فالمغيرات
صبحا فاثرن به نقعا فوسطن به جمعا ان
الانسان لربه
لكنود وانه على ذلك
لشهيد وانه لحب الخير
لشديد افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في القبور
وحصل ما في
الصدور ان ربهم بهم يومئذ
لخبير بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم القارعه ما
القارعه وما ادراك ما القارعه يوم يكون
الناس كالفراش
المبثوث تكون الجبال كالعهن
المنفوش فاما من ثقلت
موازينه فهو في عيشه
راضيه واما من خفت
موازينه
فامه هاويه وما ادراك ما هي نار
حاميه الله
اك
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المست
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الهاكم التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر كلا
سوف
تعلمون ثم كلا سوف
تعلمون الا لو تعلمون علم
اليقين
لترون
الجحيم ثم
لترونها عين
اليقين ثم
لتسالن يومئذ عن
النعيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والعصر ان
الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا
صالحات وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ويل لكل
همزه لمزه الذي جمع مالا وعدده يحسب ان
ماله اخلده كلا
لينبذن في الحطمه وما ادراك ما الحطمه نار
الله الموقده التي تطلع على
الافئده انها عليهم مؤصده في عمد
ممدده بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الم تر كيف فعل ربك باصحاب
الفيل الم يجعل كيدهم في
تضليل وارسل عليهم طيرا ابابيل
ترميهم
بحجاره من
سجيل فجعلهم
كعصف
ماكول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لايلاف قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي اطعم هم من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
ا
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
صلاه الشف ان شاء الله ختم باذن الله
نستقيم وست الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ارايت الذي يكذب
بالدين فذلك ك الذي يدع
اليتيم ولا يحض على طعام
المسكين فويل للمصلين الذين هم عن صلاتهم
ساهون الذين هم
يراءون ويمنعون
الماعون بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا
اعطيناك الكوثر فص صل لربك وانحر ان شانئك
هو الابتر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل يا
ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
لكم دينكم
وليدين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا جاء نصر الله والفتح ورايت الناس
يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره انه كان
توابا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تبت يدا ابي
لهب وتب ما اغنى عنه ماله وما كسب سيصلى
نارا ذات لهب وامراته
حماله الحطب في ها
حبل من مسد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيم
استو
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم قل اعوذ برب الفلق من شر ما خلق
ومن شر غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر
النفاثات في العقد ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم قل اعوذ برب
الناس ملك
الناس اله
الناس من شر الوسواس
الخناس الذي يوسوس في صدور الناس من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه ملء السماء والارض وملء ما
بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل الثنا
والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك عبد لا
مانع لما اعطيت ولا معطي لما منعت ولا راد
لما قضيت ولا ينفع ذا الجد منك الجد اللهم
صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم اجعل القران العظيم ربيع
قلوبنا ونور ابصارنا وجلاء همومنا
واحزاننا اللهم ذكرنا منهما نسينا وعلمنا
منه ما جهلنا وارزقنا تلاوته اناء الليل
واطراف النهار على الوجه الذي يرضيك عنا
اللهم اجعله لنا حجه يا رب
العالمين اللهم انا نسالك خير المساله
وخير الدعاء وخير العلم وخير العمل وخير
الحياه وخير
الثواب اللهم ثبتنا وثقل
موازيننا وحقق ايماننا وارفع
درجاتنا ونسالك العلى من الجنه اللهم ان
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيه
ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك ومن اليقين
ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا ومتعنا
اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا وقوتنا ما
احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا
على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبه في ديننا ولا تجعل
الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا الى
النار مصيرنا ولا تسلط علينا من لا يخافك
ولا يرحمنا ربنا لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا
غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا مريضا الا
شفيته ولا ميتا الا رحمته ولا مبت الا
عافيته ولا مكروبا الا فرجت عنه يا رب
العالمين ولا حاجه من حوائج الدنيا هي لك
رضا ولنا فيها صلاح الا قضيتها ويسرتها يا
اكرم
الاكرمين اللهم انا نعوذ بك من الهم
والحزن ونعوذ بك من العجز والكسل ونعوذ بك
من الجبن والبخل ونعوذ بك من غلبه الدين
وقهر الرجال اللهم انا نعوذ بك من الكفر
والفقر ونعوذ بك من عذاب القبر لا اله الا
انت اللهم رب اللهم حبب الينا الايمان
وزينه في قلوبنا وكره الينا الكفر والفسوق
والعصيان واجعلنا من راشدين ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا وثبت اقدامنا
وانصرنا على القوم الكافرين ربنا لا تزغ
قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك
رحمه انك انت الوهاب ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا وذر ياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا
للمتقين اماما ربنا اغفر لنا ولاخواننا
الذين سبقونا
بالايمان ولا تجعل في قلوبنا غلا للذين
امنوا ربنا انك رؤوف رحيم ربنا لا تجعلنا
فتنه للقوم الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك من
القوم الكافرين الله اللهم انك عفو تحب
العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو
فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف
عنا
اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واكتب لنا ثوابها
واكتب لنا ثوابها وجعلنا من
عتقائك من النار ومن المقبول
لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا من
الظالمين اللهم يا ذا الجلال والاكرام يا
ذا الفضل
والانعام من على اخواننا المستضعفين في
غزه والسودان بالنصر والتمكين كلهم عونا
ونصيرا كل لهم عونا ونصيرا كل لهم عونا
ونصيرا
اللهم اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من خوف اللهم
دمر على عدوك
وعدوهم اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تذر
منهم احدا انهم يا رب لا يعجزونك اللهم
ارغم انوف
المستكبرين اللهم اذل الظالمين اللهم اضرب
الظالمين بالظالمين واخرج المسلمين من
بينهم سالمين اللهم مكن لامه محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم في الارض اللهم ع اللهم خذ
بنواصينا اليك اخذ الكرام عليك اللهم خذ
بنواصينا اليك اخذ الكرام عليك اللهم
وفقنا لخيري الدنيا والاخره من العلم
النافع والعمل الص وحسن الخاتمه يا اكرم
الاكرمين اللهم بارك في ارزاقنا ووسع في
بيوتنا وبارك في ازواجنا وفي اولادنا
واغفر لنا ولابائنا
وهات ولاصحاب الحقوق علينا واغفر للمؤمنين
والمؤمنات والمسلمين والمسلمات
احياء
وامواتا لا لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا
من الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا
كنا من الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك
انا كنا من
الظالمين اللهم يا واسع الفضل والمغفره من
علينا برحمتك وهدايتك
وتوفيقك في الدنيا والاخره ارزقنا العفو
والعافيه في الدنيا والاخره صل وسلم وبارك
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين وصلى الله وسلم وبارك عليه
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
سلام السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله السلام عليكم
مك
اللهه
[Silence]
‏so
ان شا
[Silence]
الله
شاء
‏salato spe midnight midn
[Silence]
yes
شا
[Silence]
عل
‏m
[Silence]
ا
م